(students cheering)
- Your middle school and high school years
are the end of the beginning
as you march off to college,
as you march off to grad school,
and all the jobs and
careers that you want.
(students cheering)
(applause)
(students chanting)
- [Thomas] All right, Class of 2018!
(students cheering)
The mission of WHEELS is to make sure
that all of our students
are academically, emotionally,
socially, and intellectually prepared
to succeed in the college of their choice.
We expect that 100% of our
seniors apply to college,
and then it's up to
them and their families
to make the right decision
that that's for them.
(students cheering)
Based on the idea that
it's to really celebrate
this process that students
have gone through.
Many of them first
generation college students.
- No one in my family has gone to college.
When I mention it to my family,
they're very like, "I
can't really tell you much
because I've never been there."
- You guys made it to the College March.
- [Thomas] The day starts
with a bunch of different activities.
They open up letters from their families.
- So you'll get your parent letter.
- (speaking in Spanish)
- They got their hoodies,
which is a huge deal.
It's them really being
part of something larger.
- Everybody was like, "Oh, my
god, it's the College March."
It didn't hit me until we were lined up.
(students cheering)
- [Thomas] All the
students from our school
line both sides of the pavement.
Streets are shut down.
Family's there. Community
members are there.
- In the youngest grades,
we have our students
participate on the sidelines.
So they're seeing, for the first time,
young people who look them
who are going off to college
and seeing the community support that.
- It's like motivation,
I guess you can say,
because, when we see them,
we're like, "I'm gonna
be going off to college,
and I'm gonna have everybody
else cheering me on
one of these days."
- They really look up to us,
and it was amazing to just
walk through the streets
and inspire them that the college process
shouldn't be that intimidating.
(students cheering)
(drums beating)
- Because this is one of
many monumental moments
in your life.
- We always have alumni
and then we have some community
members share as well.
- Every door that you walk through,
remember that you
represent this community.
Hold your head up high
and know that you can do
exactly what your goals are.
(students cheering)
- Obviously, we have one
more thing left to do, right?
(students cheering)
- We have our students each
with an individualized envelope
that contains their supporting documents.
- The highlight of the entire experience
was when we physically took the copy.
- [Thomas] Come on up!
- And put it in the box to be mailed out,
knowing that, when we release
it, it's going to college.
It's just amazing.
I could do it over and over again.
- Every year, it gets a little bit bigger,
a little bit louder.
And it's now spread to 25
schools across the country.
- And congratulations
again to the Class of 2018.
(students cheering)
(applause)
- And of course, it's not the end.
It's just a symbol that we're closing
this chapter of our lives
and opening the other one,
which is college and beyond.